on parle bien d'une baisse du budget
global de la politique agricole commune
quand jean claude juncker dit qu'entre
la politique de cohésion et
l'agriculture qui pèse aujourd'hui 70%
du budget européen on doit arriver à
réduire ces pôles de ces politiques
on est assez clair ah mais c'est lui qui
le dit ça n'est pas ce que ce n'est pas
la position française n'est pas la
position de française nous portant une
ambition forte pour l'europe ça veut
dire qu'il faut un budget lui aussi
ambitieux pour répondre aux attentes de
nos concitoyens sur les politiques
européennes c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
fait des consultations citoyennes
au moment où nous allons négocier le
futur budget c'est-à-dire les futures
priorités d'action de l'union européenne
il vaut mieux le faire autrement que
dans la bulle de bruxelles
en écoutant ce que les européens nous
demande